今日は平成17年度テーマ県砺波市陸上競技大会小学6年生の部1500m 走に立っ
た肇社長です短距離走
あると思うんですよ僕に人気というか有名な仲間100m そうなんですけども
100m 走皆さん速く走りたいと思ったことありませんか
そう100m とただハウス加茂タイプっていうのは変わらない困難です
そこで私が覚えていてしまいました競争相手強い競争相手ライバルがいればいう人間
ってのは強くなる
その原理を利用するとが普通にハ染色メートルのためによりもっと速いタイムが出す
保護あると思うよ
そこへ準備するのか
ドッド s 6を使って今日はビッグぞ先ほどそうやっていきたいと思います警察に
なる上司ている訓練健全日しましためっちゃせるの早いと思うんでねその後出す走れば
自然とその晩茶と同じ系だって加速して僕も早くだけこれぞっつを効果っていうかね
ちょっとなるかわかんないんですけどもその亜種アイワンちゃん訓練原発走ればタイム
も速くなる
づらいかということでちょっと何パターンか準備してなんとかして会がする方法を探し
て行きたいと思いますデーが浮かぶよ
[音楽]
いやいやいや
またなるよねー
待てん
ん
ほんと姉じゃあなんです
さあやってまいりました世界陸上の人間 vs 犬
日本人代表肇社長選手か死ぬのはそんなに速くない様子です最近運動不足ですが物件
だけ力株
まずは一人で走りの基本となるた餌を図っていきましょう
これが基準となりますサーカス皆さん意外と体を覚えが
まあ割と早いさあ
だいたいせいぜいになって13秒14秒台とか早い方と言われておりますが今どれ
都市だタイムが一人の初武器
ずう3秒31です比較てくれるんですか
だぜん
ちゃーん
影がたピョンかい
[音楽]
うっ何もませんだろさー釣りでは vs パピオン
日本人たちの肇社長選手先ほど1本走ってちょっと疲れがたまっている子様2です
どういう走りを見せてくれるでしょうか対する相手は不可 po
かわいいおいいねサーです小さいですこれを以下切るというより一緒に走ってたは
バレるという表現がたら
しどうでしょうかった霊性が捧げます
いいいいただいいスピード勝負だと思ったら全然そんなことはなかったハルクに触れる
社長選手のが遅い
発表さでば秒速いかなり差が開いて行きます圧倒的なスピードの遅さでファンミョン
ゴールドして肇社長ゴール多い
ん
うん
うんっ
素材でございますうん
14秒されるわけです
エルダーやハイヤーちっちゃい子連チャンで速いのか
うん
てるんだぜっ
油がでデートリーバー中の有名なおいぬさんですさあ
見た目は大きいのですがそのスピードがいかなるものなのでしょうか
今後ろに立っております今回ははじめしゃちょーテンションを追いかけるという形で
教務主任を哀れだからのレースになりますございますどうぞよしっマッハ
それと思い日早いラブラブモードれするかはやいはやふるぎるー
苦しみの声を上げながらゴールに向かってかすみ草しかしはるかにさわひらき先に頃は
ラブラドールレトリバーば
続いてゴールが母にタイプで限り都度選手
8サイバーのたい
2緑髪初ですね
遅くなっちゃった義母対極的なアレなんだろうな
[音楽]
いやいやいやいやいや待てマテ待てマテ待てを待ってますよまあね早瀬を不安なんて
いうんですか
てしまうぞ
絶対はそれでねその名前だけさあ連れての者へ弾み社長選手日本人代表3本目のレース
です体力がまだ残っているのでしょうか対数相手は警察犬の訓練犬
未来の警察犬のシェパード組んでさあ
恐ろしい筋肉量を持っているながとても優秀で賢い犬でございます
後ろから追いかけられるという状況でベースがをご存知ていきますさ恐怖心を使って
どこまで自分のカラーに打つ打って
フィードを高めることができるのか初めて挑戦してさシェパードいい
あっというふうに取れてしまった何度 you feel なるでしょうか
その差は一気に開いていけ4番とゴール続いて外れると手順を a
はぁ
ただいまのタイム
根津4秒40
遅くなりました恐怖感はあるん背負われている
命のヤバさは感じですけど抜かれてからなんかもう雑貨にやられたって館あの
次がもリマスター続いてはもうなんかよくわかんないよねシェパードを5匹鍋で一緒に
走ってみましょう
どんだけ恐ろしい筋肉量を守った警察点が5匹
隣にいるとさとかし強いことでしょうさあこの恐怖心の中走ることによって
はじめ自動停止のタイプはどのように変わっていくのでしょうかさあ5匹の芝との紹介
は全部同じですまことにモーション
でございません
さあで預かってもらって知っていますこの5匹に追われる気持ち
なかなか強いのでは9章が始まった安積蘇生させる
こういうかけるシェパード一気さーんなこれはまるでうわあああっもう
女性してくれる優しいシャーパーいる
これ仲良くそれでグーッと見せかけて
リーダーの外れるとメッセージしたん
[音楽]
うさい53秒 his money
最後だけ13秒ですねあの最初除いてあの小説でも体力の限界だった介は2月の記帳
感じて最後の退職嘘って13秒が達者で結果
犬に終わると
早くなる体力があれば12秒で出たと思うんだよ
さあ強かったんでもやんないしお疲れです
[音楽]
car
me
あっはぁ